almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it Democratic
presidential candidates had their final
debate last night before Saturday South
Carolina's primary and then also the
last debate before Tuesday's March 3rd
Super Tuesday contests which will
include maybe enough primaries to really
get a definitive sense of the path
forward for this nomination could Bernie
get 50% plus one is it more likely that
there will not be any candidate getting
to that threshold or far less likely but
still possible will some other candidate
get the 50% plus one before the
convention now I'm not going to do a
full review of the debate last night
with a whole bunch of clips because
quite frankly it was very similar to
last week's debate except with worse
moderation it was again this kind of
ultimate fighting type debate with many
candidates coming in and we knew they
would do it going after Bernie Sanders
who's now the presumptive frontrunner
the moderation was absolutely atrocious
people constantly talking over each
other that applies both to multiple
moderators talking at the same time
while multiple candidates talk at the
same time cutting people short of their
75 seconds but at the same time letting
some candidates go too long it was a
complete and total mess but the overall
assessment of what went on last night
for me is that Joe Biden came in with a
bunch of energy he didn't say anything
different but he at least looked more
energetic than he has before maybe he
would get himself a small boost the
crowd was not particularly friendly to
Bernie and there's a backstory there as
well a lot more booing of Bernie and
cheering of Joe Biden and Michael
Bloomberg and that's not reflective of
anything other than the people that got
seats in that room some of them paying
quite a bit in order to be in that room
I don't think anybody really did
particular damage to their
own campaign I don't expect polling to
move very much I think if anything Biden
maybe gets a slight boost because he
just seemed more alive last night but
it's important to know and we're gonna
get to the polling data later as bad as
Michael Bloomberg's performance was in
last week's debate Bloomberg was totally
unaffected in the polls he did not drop
in the polls after last week's debate so
by showing up last night and being
slightly prepared like I don't think
Michael Bloomberg's responses were great
yesterday and in fact he had some
atrocious responses which we will talk
about I don't think that Michael
Bloomberg is going to see any decline in
polls and in Super Tuesday polls he's
actually doing okay which is why I want
to focus on this next clip Michael
Bloomberg had an unbelievable Freudian
slip last night where he was defending
his support of Democrats historically
and the reason he was doing this is he
was attacked by some candidates
including Elizabeth Warren of supporting
Republicans basically saying this guy's
really a Republican is that really a
Democrat Michael Bloomberg was prepared
and he fought back by talking about all
the money he's given to Democrats
including many Democrats who won races
in the 2018 midterm and he slipped and
said that he had bought members of
Congress and immediately caught himself
mid-sentence we noticed the Freudian
slip live during our stream before the
stream was shut down which I'll talk
about a little bit later let's take a
look at the clip here it is the height
of oligarchical nonsense Michael
Bloomberg admitting that he bought
members of Congress and then realizing
I'm not really supposed to be saying
that that's not what I'm supposed to be
saying take a look all of the new
Democrats that came in put Nancy Pelosi
in charge and gave the Congress the
ability to control this president I got
them number two I bought her I I got
them and I tweeted about this right when
it happened saying Bloomberg Freudian
slip they're almost said he bought the
current Congress anyone noticed that and
indeed people did woke up to a whole
bunch of articles about this this
morning some of this stuff is just
poetically perfect like it
to perfect where if you wrote in a
screenplay
about this primary and said here's an
idea let's have the super rich guy slip
and catch himself saying he bought the
current Congress now it's too
far-fetched it doesn't make we keep we
can't include that in the screenplay
nobody would believe it
this is actually more than just
Bloomberg being mostly a Republican or
mostly a Democrat Bloomberg is much like
many of these rich guys in that he's
someone who funds both sides huge
corporations and a lot of these rich
guys don't just fund Democrats or
Republicans some rich guys just on one
side that's true but a lot of these rich
guys will fund both sides so that when
they need someone here or they need
someone there they have them available
at their beck and call Bloomberg has
supported many Republicans and he
supported many Democrats he's been a
Republican and he's been a Democrat
Trump was a Democrat for a lot of his
life ran for president as a Republican
because that's where he decided he would
be able to win or potentially win a
nomination Bloomberg has been an
important funder for many Democrats and
now he himself is running for president
yeah
Bloomberg got caught here saying the
quiet part out loud but it's the same
thing Trump said during his debates with
Hillary Clinton that yeah he's made
donations and he's smart he knows how to
play the game he knows how to use money
in order to get what he wants from
politicians this is the game Bloomberg
and Trump play the same game the
difference is Bloomberg has way more
money with which to play it even buying
ads during the commercial breaks of last
night's debate people like Trump and
Bloomberg their politics are different
they're very different but Trump and
Bloomberg see the world through dollar
signs what will it cost me to buy this
or that what will it cost me
to buy this or that person you can buy
stuff supporters friends loyalty
institutions whatever you want that's
fundamentally what this is about what
they each plan to buy is where they
differ and certainly on their politics
they also do differ but a wacky and wild
evening
including Michael Bloomberg saying that
he bought the current Congress which if
you're already the guy buying his way
onto the debate stage and into probably
a bunch of different delegates in
different Super Tuesday states that's
not what you want to be caught saying
let's now talk about the polling and
Super Tuesday